the best thing is probably to get away
for a couple of days and apparently that
is what they're thinking of doing
taking a road trip possibly with oprah
did we just hear
road trip with oprah let's talk about
this for a second
yes let's so meghan markle's 39th
birthday is august 4th
and royal expert katie nicholl tells et
that there's a good chance she'll
celebrate by getting out of la
with hubby prince harry and their
one-year-old son archie
they've been at the house that they're
renting
ever since early march now they really
haven't been out much at all they
haven't seen their friends they've
they've very much been in self-isolation
and on lockdown
and it wouldn't surprise me if she just
actually needs a change of scene we do
it all
but like many of us the sussexes had to
scrap their original summer travel plans
due to the covid19 pandemic they weren't
at balmoral last summer which caused a
bit of a stink it was interpreted as
snubbing the queen
and i think given the queen's
graciousness to the couple
and there was a plan for them to come
over this summer and visit the queen
at balmoral where she will shortly
decamp
until early october but clearly we are
still in a pandemic
and the prospect of traveling is is not
appealing to the sussexes at the moment
if they're going to go and get away a
bit
i guess it will be a road trip and rumor
has it that said road trip
might lead megan harry and archie to
ladies stunning home in montecito
california
it's pure speculation that they're going
to go on a road trip with oprah
okay we said might but really this dream
road trip
isn't totally out of the question icing
on the cake yeah
the former actress has been friends with
oprah for years
you'll remember the media mogul attended
megan and harry's 2018
royal wedding and she gifted their son
archie a collection of books when he was
born
including duck rabbit which megan read
to arch on his first birthday in this
video back in may
hey look a duck that's not a duck that's
a rabbit
yeah here can you turn the page what
happens after that
what's more last year oprah spoke out in
defense of the duchess
amidst the media's depiction of her
being quote unfair
i think she's being portrayed unfairly
and i feel that if people really knew
her
they would know that she is not only
everything that we perceive or her
perceive of her as being
graceful and dynamic and holding that
position but she just has a wonderful
warm giving loving heart so i mean i see
all the crazy press around her and i
think it's really unfair
unfortunately things don't seem any
easier for the sussexes
following their royal exit and moved to
la back in march
it's not been an easy ride for them
there have been court cases
now this explosive book which has really
seen them come under fire
and nickel of course referring to
finding freedom
the book's official release isn't until
august 11th
but excerpts released earlier this week
have produced a slew of new headlines
about the sussexes
reportedly some dredging up old issues
within the royal family
at a time when things were seemingly
starting to mellow out
this is not necessarily shocking new
revelations
i think the story is familiar to all of
us now but this is the first time we are
hearing it
really from harry and megan's
perspective and reading it
in its entirety i think that makes it
compelling
and fascinating but for the royal family
yes this book has been damaging because
it has
opened up old wounds nichol tells us
that aside from the excerpts the
contents of the publication
will remain top secret until its
official release
even oprah wasn't able to get an
advanced copy of this book it has
literally been kept
under lock and key